من السهل ان نرى مالك صاله العاب رياضيه
هو نفسه المدرب المدربه رينيه جديه عندما
يتعلق الامر بالتمارين
ولكن ما قد يبدو غير واضح هنا ان خبيره
اللياقه البدنيه والبطله السابقه لبناء
الاجسام تعاني من التهاب المفاصل
الروماتيزمي وبينما لا يوجد علاج بالادويه
التي تساعد على التخفيف عن علمها يقول
طبيبها بان التفاني من اجل الاكل الصحي
والتدريبات العاديه هي المفتاح لجعل اعراض
تحت
السيطره تقول رينيه انها متحمسه جدا لانه
كما تقول فان هذه الطريقه التي اعتني فيها
بنفسي بعد ان حصلت على ما يقربني من
الليونه والرشاقه معظم الاطباء يعتقدون
بان ممارسه الرياضه فكره جيده بالنسبه
لغالب مرضى التهاب المفاصل الروماتيزمي
التي تساعد على التخفيف منها وتختلف من
شخص لاخر ويقول الدكتور جوناثان بانه
يعتقد ان تمارين الايروبيك جيده مثل الحب
الهوائي وركوب الدراجه والمشي وتمارين من
هذا القبيل وحمل الاوزان الخفيفه بالنسبه
لمعظم الناس مفيده جدا الان تقول رينيه
هناك دائما ايام جيده وايام سيئه ولكن لكي
تحقق المطلوب عليك ان تفعل افضل ما تستطيع
عمله